(audience cheering)
- Oh my God!
I know, get it out,
get it out, get it out!
I've never seen the band
clapping this hard! (laughs)
This is the first time
in four seasons I look up
and they're like, Yeah, woo! (claps)
So wait, I hear you came with a request
of some sort, did you?
- Oh, he is a Hamilton super-fan,
- I am, we all are.
- And especially-
- Who isn't?
- Your rendition of "It's Quiet Uptown."
- Well, that's nice!
- He sings it often.
- That's your favorite?
- That's my favorite.
- That's a sad song, man!
- It puts me into a relaxing stage,
it makes me appreciate life.
- Oh, an optimist! Cause
that's a dark song.
- Yeah, I try to take the
positives out of the darkness.
- You do.
If that's what you see in that
song, you are an optimist.
(all laugh)
- Thank you.
- I was pregnant with my
son when I had to sing that
and I hadn't seen Hamilton
yet and I was like,
(mock sobbing) it was just
the saddest thing ever.
But God, what a great musical.
You saw it obviously,
right? Like how many times?
- We're super-fans.
- I know, me too.
- It's a problem.
- We corner Lin when we see him.
(Kelly laughs)
Tell us more.
- I corner him, make
him show up at my show.
I'm like, Please come back, I love you.
So wait, you recently celebrated,
is it your eighth anniversary?
- (in unison) Yeah.
- That's amazing!
(audience applauds)
I heard there's something
called the Wade World Tour.
What is this and how do you get invited?
(audience laughs)
- You gotta be fun!
We celebrate our anniversary
with several other couple friends-
- Oh, just got disinvited, okay. (laughs)
- There's still time, we're
both on marriage number two.
So, still time.
We celebrate together, we all
celebrate our anniversaries
and we figure out ways of
loving each other better.
- [Kelly] That's awesome! You
all do it together on a trip?
(audience applauds)
- [Gabrielle and Dwayne] Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's really fun! Oh my God!
So that's a yacht, okay.
- Yeah, that's us working
on our relationship.
- We like to travel.
(Kelly laughs)
- I'm like, usually people go to therapy,
y'all go to like, paradise.
- We go and get away from
everybody so it's just us.
- [Kelly] It's smart.
- [Dwayne] It's just us 12,
we gotta deal with it all.
Did y'all see that?
(audience cheers)
- And you enjoy each other in
a dating capacity, probably.
That's romantic, that's nice.
- Well it's like you kind
of meet each other again,
away from kids, away from work,
out in the middle of nowhere,
and you gotta kind of figure
out how to love each other
and like each other better.
- What have been your favorite
stops on the Wade World Tour?
- One of my favorite stops was,
we were in the South of France, as one is-
- That's nice, I've been there.
- We're obsessed.
And we were going to this place for lunch
and they were like, Oh my gosh,
Elton John is always there.
- Shout out to Pecos, our friend.
- Yeah, our friend Pecos.
He's like, Elton John's always
there and he's always singing
and we're like, That's not
gonna happen when we go.
- What? Didn't happen
when I went anywhere.
- And who's there?
- [Kelly] No way!
- Elton John.
(audience applauds)
Cut to, you hear the first chords
of all of your favorite Elton John songs
and he's like, No I could never!
And he stands up and proceeds
to do a full concert.
The whole place goes nuts.
- Legendary.
- It was unbelievable.
- That's so crazy!
- What's your favorite,
though? Your favorite memory.
- Oh, my favorite memory?
- Or like, place to go if
y'all go different places.
- Calvin Harris?
- Well yes, this year we was in Spain
and we got an opportunity in Ibiza
to see Calvin Harris.
- I really wanna be a part of your lives.
So like wait, what? I'm doing
something wrong. (laughs)
(audience claps)
- You see, Calvin Harris and
the way he controls the crowd
is amazing.
I've heard a lot of great things about him
and first time being at the show,
it was raining, it was
thunder, it was lightning.
It was everything that you can ask for
and Calvin Harris was doing his thing.
So I was out there, shirt
off, just like ah! Screaming.
It was amazing.
- Oh, that's such a great feeling,
being lost in music like that.
I feel like we missed
that for a couple years
cause we weren't really allowed to gather.
God, it's like you get
drunk off that energy now.
- Or drunk off other things.
- [Kelly] Yes, or...(laughs)
A good time with help.
(audience clapping)
- It was Ibiza.
There might have been
something in the air.
- [Kelly] There's songs about it.
- Some herbal essence in the air.
But we were so into it,
cause we never really do the Deuce Deuce,
we're more of, Kelly Clarkson,
Patti LaBelle, Beyonce.
- Can I just, wow! I love
the company, thank you!
I don't belong in that
sentence, but I like it.
- So we don't know.
So we see this plane go over, we're like,
Oh yo, they're pulling out all the stops!
We think this is a part of the show.
It starts raining, the wind,
there's actual lightning.
We're in danger, we're like, Oh!
- This is amazing.
- This is amazing!
The production value is really top-notch.
- It's probably that herbal thing.
You're like, This is awesome!
- Everyone's leaving, we like,
What are they leaving for?
This is great!
- This is the best!
(Kelly laughs)
Like Dwayne Wade died today.
- I wanna go on vacation
with y'all just to watch.
(audience applauds)
- So has it been nice
to have Dwayne at home
since retiring, is that nice? (laughs)
- It has gotten nice.
(audience laughs)
Initially, our careers
were on opposite coasts
so we were never really home together
for long stretches of time.
So it would be like, every
morning, Oh! There you are.
(Kelly laughs)
Look at his face!
Over time, it's awesome.
- [Kelly] It's probably
weird for you, too!
- Thank you. No one ever
asks me, Is it weird?
- You know why? Cause
that's like musicians,
we're on the road all the time
and that can be hard in a relationship.
Then you try and almost put
yourself in this situation,
the family's already kind
of doing its own thing
while you've been gone, so that's hard.
- Yes, so I just had to be quiet
for like the first six months.
- (laughs) Good job, that's hard.
- Yeah, just shut up and listen.
I've found my space now in the house.
The rent I pay, I feel like
I'm getting my money's worth.
- (laughs and claps)
I'm a part, I'm a part.
- [Dwayne] Get my money's worth.
- You've been married for eight years,
so is there anything that drives you nuts,
I know there's something
that drives you nuts,
about the other person?
- We gotta pick one thing, or...?
- (laughs) I got a list.
- He acts like there's the
Dead Sea Scrolls of complaints.
- All the guys in here,
what's up, how y'all doing?
So can I go first?
- I just wanna steal that! (laughs)
Dead Sea Scrolls of complaints! Go ahead.
- So my wife stopped
driving a few years ago.
She got into a few fender-benders...
- Maybe realized it wasn't your thing.
- [Gabrielle] Not my thing.
- So it wasn't her thing and
I was all for it, so I drive.
When she gets in the passenger seat,
she tells me how to drive,
all the time. All the time.
She never drives but she
tells me how to drive.
- You're my sister.
Every time we're in the car
with she and Sean, her husband,
I'm like, Lisa, let him drive!
She's always got something to say
and I'm like, Why don't you drive?
That's you! That's you.
- I was going 20 miles
an hour the other day,
she's like, Slow down!
- We were in a school zone.
We rarely get to do the drop-off,
our youngest daughter's drop-off,
and I just felt like it was
Mario Andretti out there.
I'm like, Pump the brakes, sir!
- (laughing) You are my sister!
- It felt faster than he was...
I think it's my turn though, hold on.
(audience laughs)
- I was hoping like the
time ran, like commercial.
- He snores, he is a snorer.
- If I'm on my back.
- He knows he snores.
(audience laughs)
- If I'm on my back!
- If you know you snore
on your back, turn over.
- You can't control that in your sleep.
- Thank you.
- That's what he thinks.
- It's only because age
hit and I started snoring
and I was like, This is not hot.
- I didn't know we was coming
to therapy, this is great.
Thank you, Kelly.
- But it's not just enough that he snores,
he brings our dog, Trey,
who's a little Frenchie.
His little nose is like this
big and they snore together.
(audience exclaims)
- Oh no.
- It's like a symphony of snoring
and Trey is very territorial.
He's like, That's my man, girl.
He always has to be in-between us
and normally, when it was
just him in bed snoring,
I would just give him
a little rabbit punch
and he was like, What, what?
And I'm like, I don't
know, something happened.
(Kelly laughs)
And that would stop.
So last night, he brought the dog in
and he forgot to take him
out and I'm petting Trey,
I'm like, Oh baby, did you have a big day?
Next thing I know, he's peed on my feet.
And I'm like, Baby!
So before we even got to
the snoring, there was dog-
- [Kelly] Pee.
And that sucks when you're tired.
That's happened to me too, we have a puppy
in our house right now and you're like,
Oh cool, I'll just go ahead
and change all the sheets
right now at 10:30, that's nice. (laughs)
I wasn't tired or anything, it's fine.
So your youngest daughter
is almost four now
and she's quite the dancer.
Everybody take a look at this.
- [Gabrielle] I love this!
(audience awwing)
- [Kelly] Look, she is so focused!
- [Dwayne] She's serious.
- [Kelly] This is my daughter
at dance, by the way.
Yeah, she is so focused.
- [Dwayne] We give pep
talks, before we go in.
- Are y'all those parents like,
Baby smile? Are you those?
- It's like when she look at, Smile!
- I just feel like we put a lot of work in
and it's time to deliver, you know?
(audience laughing)
- It's time to deliver.
- [Gabrielle] It's time to deliver.
Not unlike me, how I was at
his games, where I was like,
Let's go, three! Let's go, three!
Come on now, free throws are
free for a reason, let's go!
So perhaps I'm not the best dance mom.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- I just say to Kaav, I
just say, That's your mom.
Kaav try to look at me
cause mom is over here,
I'll be like...
- [Kelly] Look at me.
- Focus on me.
- Calm.
- She's a little stressed.
- She's excited.
- So Kaav focuses on dad.
(audience cheering)
- So you two have now created
a line of baby products called Proudly.
What can you tell us about
it and why'd you start it?
- We created the line because we realized
there was a gross lack
of quality, safe products
that centered the needs
of melanated children,
and knowing that we have
access to everything
and we couldn't find it for our child.
We started talking to
other parents of color
and we were all realizing that
our kids were overindexing
on skin concerns, like
eczema, extreme dryness,
cradle cap, diaper rash, that looked-
- [Dwayne] It's just dark skin.
- Baby acne and our
children were overindexing
and we realized that even
though there are products
that say "Safe for children,"
they aren't the best
for melanated children.
We have different skin needs
and we wanted to meet those needs.
- That's amazing.
So why did you name it Proudly?
- I think it's just that, right?
We're proud of this brand.
We hope that families,
this is gonna be something
that they're gonna be proud
to introduce to their homes.
It's hard to introduce new things.
We all like things that we like
and our grandparents like,
and our parents like,
but we want them to be proud to introduce
something that we feel that...
Shout out to our
dermatologist out the Beach,
shout out to our pediatrician,
Dr. McGowan, our entire team.
We're proud of the structure
we were able to put together.
We partnered up with A-Frame,
it's an amazing company,
and we said, This is what we
want our team to look like,
this is what we want it to feel like.
We want it to look like the people
that we're trying to
make these products for,
and that's what our team looks like.
- 90% of our team is women,
95% are people of color.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Wow, which is important!
- It's important because-
- You're working on a product
that's for the...
- Oftentimes you'll be like,
Who designed these
feminine hygiene products,
things that women use, and you're like,
It's a bunch of dudes!
How do you know about-
- That's what I say about heels.
- Exactly, torture devices.
- That was a man.
That was a dumb person's idea.
I'm mad about it still.
And it was invented, I think,
for kings to feel taller.
I'm suffering cause you felt short?
(audience laughs)
I'm mad about it.
- But that's the thing.
It's like, Who's making these products
and are you just trying to
exploit people who have needs?
In creating this company for us, by us,
by people of color for children of color,
and the majority of the people
that work for us are parents.
So we're creating the products
that we wanna use in our own homes.
So it creates a very proud, united front.
- I love that that's
when it happens though,
it's like something you need
and you want and you desire
and you're like, Look, not
everybody can make this happen.
You have the power to
actually make that happen,
not only for yourselves
but for other people.
- The resources.
- You have the resources.
- Yeah, you have the networking,
you have all of that.
So it's really awesome for y'all
but also how you're
helping so many others.
- The best things come
out of outta need, right?
So to be able to create
a product and a brand
out of something that is
a real need in the world,
we're proud of that.
So the name just kind of, it made itself.
- Yeah, Proudly. That's cool.
- Target was like, what? We want in!
(audience applauds)
- I love Target.
- Don't I look like a Proudly parent?
- It's hard to get in Target!
- It's hard to get in Target.
- [Kelly] I don't know if y'all know that.
- Shout out to Target.
- Immediately they were
like, We want this.
- That's awesome!
- So we're in-
- That store, you go in for
two things and leave with 50,
and not one was the two
things you went in for.
(all laugh)
So is Kaavia, is she a
part of your focus group?
Does she test out your stuff?
- She is the focus group.
- Oh yeah.
- If she didn't like it,
we will never see it.
- [Kelly] They're so honest about it.
- [Gabrielle] They're painfully honest.
- [Dwayne] But she has to
be able to do it herself.
- [Kelly] Oh, independent!
- So we had to make sure
that the product was made
to a point where it was
easy for her to use.
- For all toddlers to be able to use.
- The caps and the tops and everything.
- My little girl loves that.
She hates when I have to help her,
she loves the independence of it.
- She was getting it, she couldn't use it,
so we had to go back and say,
No, we want a different cap,
we want a different top.
All these things was important
for Kaav to use 'em herself.
- But we used our whole family.
Anyone that we knew with
babies, small children,
everyone became our focus group.
I looked down one day
and I was like, Ooh, baby
those knuckles are ashy!
- [Kelly] Perhaps not
his finest hour. (laughs)
- [Gabrielle] And I was
like, Well, if this can work,
we're in business.
- [Kelly] (laughs) I
love what's happening.
You two, your house
must be so insanely fun.